[Música]
oi meu nome é lucas tem 11 anos e hoje
vou contar pra vocês como a tecnologia
ajuda no esporte
sabia que jogam pólo aquático
isso porque a minha mãe foi da seleção
brasileira me incentivou a jogar um dia
quero ser medalhista olímpico
para isso preciso de sonhos treino
dedicação e mais a tecnologia talvez um
dia eu consiga
gerson diz vocês conhecem ele é sobrou
mundo nas olimpíadas de 1936 criando
quatro medalhas mas saber que ele usou
tecnologia colo a adidas fez sapatilhas
são exclusivas para eles olha essa
competição
agora vou dividir a tecnologia em três
grupos
a tecnologia nos treinos tecnologias
equipamentos e tecnologia na alimentação
tecnologia na alimentação mais e mais as
empresas vêm desenvolvendo novas
tecnologias da alimentação é para o
melhor desenvolvimento dos esportistas
nas competições
essas são as super fofos como me
proteínas aminoácidos suprimento
alimentar mas sempre com ela ou com
acompanhamento das duas redes gremistas
tecnologia e equipamentos
essa é uma área onde a tecnologia ajuda
muito como ciclismo materiais mais leves
na bike pneus mais eficientes na fórmula
1 para cada pista como pista molhada
pista seca que está mais ou menos é
barista eletrônicas que o técnico de
juízes conseguem ver quem muito e não
queimou a largada supermaiôs chegaram
até ser proibidos mas hoje eles são
feitos com pele de tubarão para ter o
melhor de si e são cinco são simulados e
pele de tubarão para ter o melhor deles
na água tecnologia nos treinos
essa marca
os técnicos conseguem ver o ponto forte
o ponto fraco do esportista como robôs
que simulam movimentos como o twiter box
big data capture captura de informações
e análises em pouco tempo
maggi tal uso de peões que ajuda a mudar
o desempenho do esportista
o que eu vos a tecnologia trouxe para o
nosso dia a dia
saber que até as pessoas normais se
beneficiam com a tecnologia no esporte
elas ganham carros mais eficientes
temos mais confortáveis e até avanço de
alimentação
agora precisa me pedir que é preciso
trilhar mas fica a pergunta será que
consigo chegar não pode rezar e pedir
muito obrigado